[Applause]
it was a long night that ended with a
raucous celebration but George and
Maloney and her supporters her brothers
of Italy party will lead a right-wing
Coalition after a very clear electoral
Victory Maloney the socially
conservative populist promising tax cuts
and change is destined to be prime
minister
if we will be called to govern this
country we will do it for all Italians
for everybody with the goal of uniting
this people of stressing what unites
rather than what divides foreign
will lean on some volatile Partners
including the league led by matthio
salvini Keen to see this as a long-term
partnership
the governments rarely do serve the full
term here and the low turnout suggests a
public weary of the political status quo
this country woke up to a brand new
political landscape the brothers of
Italy have never held power before while
Georgia Maloney will become this
nation's first woman prime minister it's
a clean start and that's exactly what
Maloney supporters really wanted while
her opponents say they worry about her
radical agenda
the new Coalition will be tough on
immigration for instance in a country
where one in 10 people were born abroad
that is an unsettling idea for some
bright and Kevin came here from Nigeria
you as a prime minister
you're supposed to tackle the problem of
this country not for you to tackle
immigrants but don't have nothing to do
with you there's a big problem here in
Italy first of all work love
there's no work here there's nothing
there's nothing enough for you to return
okay look how homeless people every year
the last month has been all about Flags
posters and pledges but now comes the
hard bit Maloney is going to have to
live up to her campaign rhetoric and
that could be divisive and expensive
Adam Parsons Sky News Rome